now I would like you to call your mind
back to this okay now you do not need to
redraw this but there will be an extra
bit that you might want to right next to
where you do your diagram yesterday okay
so just remember we looked at
corresponding angles just like that
example we just did right I
corresponding a look like this have a
look closely okay I'll zoom in there now
why do we call them corresponding what
is it that makes like why are these two
corresponding and like not say these two
they look pretty cool they could be
friends why is it those two yeah very
good so you can see my arrows there I've
tried to help us see right they are
facing in the same direction so that's
why they correspond to each other so
here's my summary here that I've written
Julia that way Charlie just so you can
see the whole thing um you've already
got this diagram from yesterday earth it
probably have a few extra things a lot
actually so you don't need to a
replicator they called corresponding
because they face the same direction and
we look at that by measurement remember
we looked it up contract on the board
you can see on your diagram that they
are about the same size and since
they're parallel the angles are you
concise so here's our conclusion see
this thing that I've written in blue
that would you copy it onto where we did
our diagram yesterday I didn't write it
I didn't sort of tied up in a neat boat
and you can put a big box around it so
it's a really important concept yes sir
I have asked you not to put him in yet
this is just what we did yesterday so go
back to what you did yesterday and I'd
like you to add I'll just highlight it
there so you can see
there we go so this is the important
part that I want to emphasize here this
is kind of our conclusion to yesterday's
investigation their corresponding angles
these guys on parallel lines these guys
they are equal for the same size okay
but but they're not the only angles that
equal on our diagram remember I said
yesterday we're going to notice a whole
bunch of interesting patterns so i want
to show you another one today right same
diagram once you have a look at this if
you wanted to wedding i'll leave it
there at the top so i hope you can see
that okay now if you look carefully at
this in fact i'm going to this is the
same diagram you just saw and I've
already got these corresponding angles
here but because I already know where's
my blue because i know not just
corresponding angles are the same
article i also know from a couple of
lessons ago that vertically opposite
angles understand do you remember that
vertically opposite so if you have a
look at this guy down here okay which
angle is vertically opposite to this one
where do I go you're Charlie this no not
yet I'll tow your threats okay um which
one can we see ya jack okay now I've got
one that does have to be top right I
just want it to be very close though so
see how this one is here I'll look at
this point and I say its opposite here
so would you all on your original
diagram you can put in than any one man
you see that those two are equal do you
agree with that okay no harm a second if
i look at this pair of angles yeah ah
wait sorry yeah because um yesterday's
I'll
yes okay all right you'll have to catch
that up later yeah you can see if I
figured out this angle down here for a
minute in fact I'm even going to get rid
of it let's see if I can be nice and
precise I feel like I'm not going to be
look I've delayed the whole line I don't
do that nevermind if you have a look at
just high def retain these two angles
here because if what we just shown are
the corresponding angles then I've got
vertically opposite do you see these two
angles must be the same size as well do
you notice that like if these two are
equal and these two are equal then these
two must be equal right so i can
conclude that these two it was the same
but they're not facing in the same
direction see how this one is facing
this way this one in fact is facing the
exact opposite way do you notice that so
even though they're facing opposite
directions this still the same size
there on these opposite sides of the
line in fact it kind of looks like if
you like I've got kind of a Zed looking
shape there okay so now you can draw
with me a new diagram use your ruler
let's get some names on this okay and
we're going to prove that these are in
fact equal okay let's call our para para
lines a b c d and just like I did before
i'm going to call this P Q R and I've
got ass down here in the court okay so
what I can say is in this diagram in
this diagram angle a Q R is equal to now
which is the end of course 22 it what
would I call it to one of the bottom
left
crs c is perfect okay so but then
they're equal and the reason is
corresponding angles now i'm going to
port you remember how we run our reasons
before and we set on parallel lines Mike
airlines have there now ok I can call
them a beam and CD so i'm going to write
that they are parallel lines by saying
this a B and then I literally put a pair
of parallel lines like this reaching as
you've seen the symbol for anyone a
small number thank you handsome but for
those who haven't met this before what
this pair of parallel lines means is
literally they're a pair of parallel
lines a lot of symbols that tell you
what they are just like the division
simple like you're literally dividing
things okay the parallel lines symbol is
literally a pair of character lines so
corresponding angles on these two
parallel lines re but then we said hey
this angle down here crs its equal to
something else angle d RQ that's this
one here like so right so you can see
I'm kind of fitting together the pieces
of a puzzle so I'm going to say see our
s equals angle D Archie and what was my
reason again that's cool you can wear
what was that reason what do we call
these are two angles together how do
they relate to each other yeah
vertically opposite very good so I'm
going to say vertically opposite angles
okay but since you've got this angle
here the first angle is equal to this
one and that's the same angle that's
equal to this third one right the first
in the third angles must also be the
same so i can say dot dot dot what does
that mean again it means therefore very
good therefore it conclusion after all
of this I can say a Q R equals G ah cute
right without without worrying about
this middle by here okay so i can say in
conclusion in words alternate angles on
parallel lines like this are equal just
like corresponding ones are so if you
like a thing you can use to help you
complete all of this remember i said
these alternate angles they're facing in
opposite directions and they kind of
make this letter and kind of make this
zedge shape here right underneath or
next to your alternate angles you aren't
like to draw a zen-like that the places
where the ultimate angles are are in
those opposite corners here and here as
it is helpful does it could face the
other way home if you like it could look
like this how many do that's not as that
but there's still alternate angles and I
can do one more sneaky way I want you to
look carefully at this diagram will be
the last thing I put on here before that
you have going mm-hmm see how i bought
these angles in whoops these angles in
blue and then alternate right I want you
to see this angle here in red mm-hmm
I know which angle will be corresponding
to this one right where's the
corresponding angle where is it yeah
right it's wet where would you like me
to go up down left right up yeah yeah so
you can teach there that's corresponding
right so I can do the same thing again
and show hey that's vertically opposite
to hear do you see that right so now I
can get rid of this one and look at
these two they look a bit weird but they
are alternate as well they are facing in
these opposite directions okay so long
with the Zeb's get me drew you can draw
kind of like some inside-out ZENIT's
they look like this those two are
alternate and here's an inside out there
those two are also known as well so long
has the directions are opposite that's
the thing you're looking for which way
are the angles facing if they're facing
the same way you've got corresponding if
they're facing opposite ways then you've
got Alton okay alright any questions on
that okay of one last thing I like I
wish no I said our thesis ends right
what kind of letter just a pair of
corresponding angles look like it
doesn't look like a Zed other have a
look yeah yeah kinda if i get rid of all
this red stuff if you can see I've got
kind of this angle here and I've got
this angle here right depending the way
you draw it it looks a little bit like
an air I think you see on their faces
separation or you could have a backwards
F or you could have an upside-down air
or you could have a upside down
backwards f okay they're all
corresponding right so it's a bit of a
shame for the style comes up with
doesn't that is it butts the pictures
will help you